hello everyone my name is Jim Wong an
assistant professor in the College of
Pharmacy University of Arizona today I'm
going to share with you our recent
progress in developing antivirus for
influenza viruses especially the
drug-resistant influenza viruses in
today's talk I'm going to introduce two
projects were currently working on why
is the discovery of channel blockers
targeting drug resistant in front of
iris M mm channel the second project is
the development of broad-spectrum
reference antivirus by targeting the
verb for Marie's PA PBY interactions for
the molecules we designed and
synthesized were interested in studying
neural control and cellular mechanism
action we are also particularly
interested in studying the mechanism of
resistance so basically why to transfer
so this cut home she see how in front of
us replicates and the carnival boy
influence antiviral drugs influenza
virus first gets into the cell by
endocytosis they release a beret which
is translocated with a new case for the
replication the newly synthesized
apparently access the nucleus to the
saddle soap words get translated to Vera
proteins the family the virus reassemble
and get released to the secretion system
to infect other cells there are three
classes of fda-approved influenza
antivirals
an Anthony and the rimantadine are the
m2 channel blockers there may be the
viral release process the other words
the axon the early stage of verification
euromillions inhibitors including acid
heavier than a mirror and parameter the
inhibits the late stage of verification
polysphere
is a peer in the linkage inhibitor
maybe the wormhole marries PA in the
Lukas activity it was approved in the
United States in 2018
and he may be the intermediate stage of
verification so as you can tell we
actually have quite a number of
influence and Deborah Gratz the question
is why we still need new ones the other
is actually drug resistance amantadine
and rimantadine are longer useful
because maturity of current circulating
in friend overseas are resistant to
these drugs and the resistance to acid
hammer has been continuously reported
and we do not know what resistance will
become redundant fellows fear is
relatively new but even in clinical
trials resistance was observed in around
10% of patients or treaty with palace
fear so overall there's a clear need of
normal divers to tackle the issue of
drug resistance to develop antivirus
tackling resistant different embarrasses
the first drug target we pursued is a MT
protein channel m2 is a very encoded
protein channel that is essential for
the bear encoding process it is a very
small variability
just like many other viral proteins it
only had 97 values and reforms a
homodimer
in the Vera mlah the proton conductance
activity is essential for the Vera
encoding process and more heals like a
mentally and rimantadine which blocks
the proton conductance can also inhibit
replication like I mentioned before
amantadine and rimantadine are longer
useful
that's because current circulating
influenza viruses of mutations in the m2
gene and the most predominant one is a
31 and mutation this is a mutation the
locus and the rock pan inside and the
mutation
from searing to asparagine leads to
amantadine resistance and the ester one
end is predominant Asian more than 95%
of consecrating influenza A viruses
contain this mutation including viruses
that are resistant to acetabular so the
idea is said if we can find a molecule
to block the proton channel function of
the st1 a new mutant this monkey will be
able to inhibit maturity of the
influenza A viruses so this is our
hypothesis so how do we design work you
to block the SNS 3-1 and mutant channel
well we didn't have a structure of the
s-1 mutant channel when we started this
project so what we did is that was to
use molecular dynamics simulations to
generate from ecology models of the s-1
and mutant according to the model the
asparagine and the position 31 bases
inside of the channel pore and there are
two possible orientations with either
the stretch a ma fizzing up or down and
we hypothesized that a monkey which is
capable of forming patented interactions
with the asparagine sidechain the ester
one mutant channel accordingly went to
different designs that target these two
different orientations so long story
short guided by this design principle
over the years we have made a few series
of compounds that have potential
blockage and entire activity against m2
as 3/1 and containing inference a versus
and yes indeed is not used not only in
the beasts amantadine resisted the
inference reverses and also as an MMA
resistant inference a very sweet
some micro model advocacy and the
highest activity index and where country
in the process of optimizing the
individual and the in vivo
pharmacokinetic established lead
compound and the testing that in vivo
endeavor advocacy in inference of errors
in fact in most models is country
ongoing so if you are interested in the
role of studies as people I was with the
cotton a three one-hitters in hand we
were also able to solve the structure
and structure of the st1 and Milton in
contracts with the structures of monkey
which is one of the most potent m23 180
meters as you can tell in the sp1 and
mutant register on the right hand side
the clock passed with this positive
charge ammonium missing out or the
n-terminal of the channel where in the
empty welcome channel which is shown on
the left hand side I mentally invite
with this positive charge ammonium
facing down for the C terminal channel
so the drug actually passed in Africa
orientation is the asturian channel
compared to the of the Weather Channel
and this structure is actually
consistent with our design principle one
mutant the two other clinically-relevant
amputations the lead understand a
mutation and the air 26f mutation both
of them located near the top and inside
so the question is how do we design
inhibitors to target is two meters they
be 2008 and air 26 F so again when we
started this project there was no
structure available for either the
weight ransom a mutant or the air 26 F
mutant so instead we again
used molecular dynamics simulations to
generate hamaji models of these two
mutants and compared them with the white
happen to structure what we found was
that both be trans them a mutant and the
artistic f mutant need to and it's panda
trepanning cavity in the channel or
comparatives and a white hat and is our
hypothesis of the inhibitors was there
we were need a boat here and extended
monkey feed in the larger cavity in this
tube mutant for in this hypothesis we
design to the size and the tested number
of molecules the most potent compound is
wg6 it is the problem conductance of
both of a Princeton a mutant and the air
26 F mutant in the two electrode voltage
and lastly with single to stop micro
molar efficacy it also inhibits a what
happened to channel WT tall sticks also
should open entire activity against all
three trans them a mutant bearers as
well as a welcome bearers in the sewer
and hilariously in the next step we want
to test the in vivo antiviral efficacy
of these Hong Kong wgo steaks we what
the experiment we did was to test this
molecule in the in vivo
Bothwell study and specifically mice
were infected with list of those of
treatments ma wearers and were treated
with diesel WT products
come on today or was it a miracle much
as a day for five days I'm Anthony was
included as the natural control because
we trans the way is resistant to
amantadine and as a camera was included
as a possible control as you can say
without treatment or infected mice died
WG 206 offered 90% survival perfection
one toast and the hundred milligram per
kg per day in comparison amantadine as a
negative negative control only 20%
protection all mice treated with
acetabular survived so overall this data
clearly shows that WG 206 as in vivo and
our advocacy and it can protect the mice
from lethal dose of we transdermal a
virus infection so this is Ray promising
as the conclusion of the first project
we confront that amantadine recent
mutants and to a stable and we traced
away and lost impressive our target
inhibitors that blocks the activity of
these mutants also inhibit verification
the mgs3 one interest actually gets most
mentally resistant and as a resistant
influenza a viruses in cell culture and
were counted with the in vivo most model
studies to test in vivo anti-balaka com2
st peters and the mtv transformational
brokers have both in vitro and in vivo
and bible advocacy now i'm pleased to
hear you talk about a second project in
the same project and we'll talk about
our efforts in developing loss spectrum
inference anti virus by toggling the
inference viral polymerase PA PB one
protein protein fractions the
high-resolution structure of the
influenza virus polymerized
was solved by x-ray crystallography west
which was shown on the left hand side
the polymerase is made of three
different subunits the P a P 1 and P b2
through non-covalent interactions and
the each domain is color-coded was shown
is the extra crystal structure of the PA
system the domain in collects with a
short peptide from the PP one and
perdóname as you can see the P is
determined domain as a concave shape
opening pocket where the PP 1 internal
peptide binds so the idea is that if we
can design small molecule to compete
with this PP 1 in terms of peptide and
implement the correct assembly of the
viral polymerase and therefore leads to
the inhibition of verification to design
repeaters that can disrupt the
parekura's PA PB 1 protein protein
interactions we have two different
approaches the first approach is the
structure based design by instakills
training in this case we took the high
nourishing x-ray crystal crystal
structure of the PhD team the domain in
compressed with the PP one and from
another method we remove the PP one in
from the peptide and encircle screening
you identify strong bodies that can fit
in the concave clock pan inside of ESPN
the domain we identify the number of
hits and we reach to the side of them
and ask them in the array size D which
is the standard storage st to detect
protein protein interactions one hit
compound compound fact should depend on
inhibition of the PA pvy interactions
wisdom is a 50 period of four points 3
micro molar in the ERISA sa this
compound also inhibits micro influence a
and B versus in the entire cast
including post proc sensitive and the
resistant viruses this is this is it's
naked because the polymerase is highly
conserved among influenza A & B viruses
and this compound can be synthesized by
the Ruby as a full coupon direction it
was that
actually index of this molecule is not
perfect so in the next pair we want to
apply medicinal chemistry the further
optimize the selectivity in that we
subsequently synthesize the number of
airlocks and the most potent compound is
compound throw away as you can see the
stretchy index increased drastically
meaning that this molecule has got an
entire activity and no not recent asset
to the house fails what still on the
left corner is the talking model of
control a in the concave drug panel
located and the PSTN domain inform the
hydrophone multiple interactions as well
as hydrophobic interactions with PhD
from the domain compre looks promising
in terms of the broad spectrum
antibiotic tivity and the selectivity
index
how about resistance in other words
where the virus Jim Mary becomes
resistant to compound from a and their
extraction pressure to answer this
question we perform the serial very
precise experiment in this experiment we
amplify the virus in the presence of
increasing drug concentration for
several passages and the qualified
approximately 50 and each passage come
from a we did not say the East a 50
increase to expand so the data is
chilled on the lower right corner which
means that no resistance emerged in
contrast the ec50 increased more than
tenfold for us at Han River which means
the worst already developed a resistance
against us at Hamburg from this
experiment we can conclude that the were
of Homer is PA PBY inhibitors such a
compound through
is the higher in ventilation barrier to
drug resistance than acceptable oh how
do you explain why the verse is not
developed resistance against a BB 1
inhibitor so I prepared this at home to
help with the explanation as we know PA
and PB 1 needs to interact former
functional memories and the PB 2 is also
required by the Forest City I didn't see
OPP - a snowball here like a PA PBY
inhibitor way pass to PA and the
previous PB 1 binding just making super
action of his America now let's assume
that PA mutates such that the compound
from a can no longer applies but from
the virus perspective it still needs
instructional polymerase to support the
verification with that is that if PA
mutates PB one also has to mutate so
that such that a mutated PA and PB one
can reconstitute perform a function of
operate in other words and the least the
two mutations 1mpa
and that neither in PB 1 are required
for the mutant virus to be post
resistant and also be able to restore
the barrel polymerase function overall
that explains the high kinetic barrier
to drug resistance of the PA PB 1
behaviors because the virus polymerase
has to develop at least two mutations
instead of one next we will key to study
the stiller and have our mechanism of
action of compound from a compound array
inhibitor very formalized so it is a key
that in a very very latest
yes indeed we observed dose dependent
inhibition of
and assist with compound treatment the
time of addition experiment showed that
compound through a inhibitor
intermediate too late speed of
verification which again agrees with the
inhibition of the verb form rest
activity the strategy I'm going to
introduce in developing PA PBY
inhibitors is first bleed Lucifer is
nasty
so freakish she's the principal of this
essay it has been shown that you can
actually take a Lucifer's enzyme under
stupid it into two halves and terminal
half understated AHA and each half
register has no end America chiefly when
the record sheet it will form a
functional and life which can transform
Lucifer II into a luminescent signal so
what this allows you to do is to apply
this si to detect
protein-protein interactions for example
we can fuse the PP one and from no
cockeyed is the n-terminal half of the
difference and fuse the PhD term the
domain Christy from now half the
difference when he be one and peptide
and the pac-10 the domain interacts it
will rain that huge half of the
difference together and restore the
enzymatic activity in fast no more kill
his PA PBY interaction the two halves of
the loop difference were no longer be
able to reconstitute and Malaysian
signal will be led in other words this
is a calculating for this se to work we
have to optimize the linker lines and
the orientation of the children
construct so the si optimization is
shown in Figure speed C and D as a
positive control the PP one n terminal
should toast dependent inhibition of the
loss inference activity
so with this optimizer
next we did a highest through
constraining of 10,000 compounds and
from this screening we identified 147
it's from the primary screening and the
top of them should stiller and
hyperactivity meaning that they can
inhibit verification in a cell culture
the most potent compound from the
screening shield broad-spectrum entire
activity against the multiple influenza
A and B viruses including viruses that
are resistant to either amantadine
rimantadine or both the next step will
be to further occupies the potency and
stability index used in medicinal
chemistry if you are interested in the
full of studies is given iOS
here comes to a conclusion of the second
project we have shown that influenza
hombres PA PB one subunit interactions
represent a high profile target GI PBY
hitters have a high in vitro a superior
to track the resistance and this is a
huge advantage over count inference
antivirus and the pap one hitters have
crossed spectrum and higher activity
against post influence and the P versus
including versus the similar to the ones
that the country is secreting when I
here are the people who have done the
hard work I also thank our collaborators
order contribution and edge from
Foundation and the ADRC for the
financial support of the study if you
have any questions or comments feel free
to email me and you can also check our
recent updates and our websites as well
thank you so much